[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear Gabby
that's it just dear Gabby no one else no
one else care deal man
I would read your advice column this is
a podcast it's comedy podcast about
death often times where two brothers but
occasionally a special guest will answer
your questions give you dubious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon and today we
are joined by Gabby done hello Gabby hi
thank you for having me on my own show
which is called dear Gabby it's great to
have you when did you start up this
advice podcast about death all by
yourself oh I would say 30 seconds ago
good well thanks so much for having me
on I really wanted to do this podcast
cause a huge fan of the work that you do
and I know that I know that you know I
want to help you promote promo your new
book that's coming out and a new tour
you're going on but also I wanted to
promote some of my own stuff so I'm
coming on the podcast to to tell people
about some of the stuff that I'm working
on well we'll get to that though have
you have you had a good good week so far
it's Monday it's like 12 o'clock on a
Monday so yeah have you had the first
good three hours of your week so far Oh
sort of we were just talking about how
neither of us are being productive today
particularly and also I didn't invite
you on my show so it's like super weird
but here the first best just like didn't
I don't know gotta talk to my Booker I
guess yeah I just showed up you just
started recording and then suddenly I
was inside of your podcasting software
yeah it's actually like pretty weird uh
but I'm so glad you're here because we
have so many questions coming up about
bisexuality and I know that you're an
expert so I'm not saying not saying that
we saved up a bunch of questions that
John and I didn't feel qualified to
answer for when we had a guest who has a
broader set of experiences than we do
but there may be more kinds of questions
like that than usual
well I honestly love to be tokenized if
people could just have me and book me on
things and give me work based on that I
would really appreciate it mom's gotta
eat so someone could all right well that
then you're in the right place cuz this
is the highest paying podcast in the
podcast business that you know podcast
by which I mean it pays the exact same
amount as all other podcast gigs which I
assume is zero dollars I have never
heard of a person being paid to be on a
podcast but maybe yeah especially my
show bad with money we pay all the
guests it's just kind of a wink to how
bad I am at money part of the show oh we
make like we make like thirty dollars an
episode and we pay fifty dollars an
episode to the guest and then I just
light a bunch of hundreds on fire just
to like you know for our yeah you gotta
be authentic
alright Gabby did you bring us a short
poem today yeah I brought a sexy poem
because I felt like that was my brand
okay so already oh god that's my goal is
this make you as uncomfortable as
possible I don't know if that's come
through and everything that I do what's
working okay so it's it's a nice one
it's a Cummings poem that I really like
and it's all just USA the title I just
read it I'll just so you can see the
title well the title is sort of the
first line or whatever so okay this is
the poem it goes I like my body when it
is with your body it is so quite new a
thing muscles better and nerves more I
like your body I like what it does I
like its house I like to feel the spine
of your body on its bones and the
trembling firm smoothness and which I
will again and again and again kiss I
like kissing this in that of you I like
slowly stroking the shocking fuzz of
your electric fur and what it is comes
over parting flesh and eyes big love
crumbs and possibly I like the thrill of
under me you quite so knew that end part
is my favorite I love that part it's so
good it's so like I don't know I just
always really that always stuck with me
I always really liked the last two lines
of that poem I never really think about
whether or not a poet like a famous poet
especially like EE Cummings or
Shakespeare it was kind of what
to what extent were their poems involved
in the process of getting them blade Oh
a hundred percent you think he wrote
that for someone not to read it to them
and be like so right so so like we we
doing mister what's the deal art is just
like people trying to be like huh
so who's someone's gonna be now right
like that's that's what we're all doing
here and then you know what sort of one
is that like a lot of these writers who
you read their their work and it's like
you know in school and stuff they show
you like the the PG work and then later
you go back and you read and you're like
oh okay like did you know shel
silverstein wrote erotica like so much
yeah I did know that I did and I was I
was upset when I found out because I was
too young it was too young to find out
was like a prolific erotica writer and
then yeah and like funny funny like
dirty drawings too like hilarious dirty
drawings and I was like 12 and there's
like shel silverstein books at my
friend's moms place and there was in
there and there was like one that was
not kids book and I was just like that
okay Oh put that back and pretend like
that never happened
yeah or like you just find I turned out
okay
did you who are you alright you're
sweating right now okay oh yeah just
this entire conversation I want out
Gabby nope
yeah I came good you're doing your job
thank you oh I'm so glad I came just to
I'd actually didn't know if this was
like a pg-13 podcast and I just went for
it
oh well we're gonna we're gonna have to
bleep some of some of you for sure
really that's allowed
do you really bleep really we believe
here on dear Hank and John John is
cursed a total of I think three times on
this podcast our guests significantly
more I don't think I've ever done it
really I'm I'm pretty good at not
cursing do you want to do it now and
then you can bleep it which what which
word should I pick
I mean probably just like Oh Goldie mr.
OH
I came here to ruin this show and I've
done my job we are nine minutes in and I
have ruined this show oh I don't know
that I feel I feel like it's going very
well I feel completely unrelated
some gay-ass question all right this
one's from Elizabeth who asks dear Hank
and Gaby greetings I'm a young queer
woman who has recently ventured into the
world of dating however I'm not out to
my parents I've been talking to this
girl for a few weeks and we've been on
one date however we're about to go on
another date tomorrow and I'm realizing
that I'll have to tell my parents where
I'm going because I might be gone for
almost the entire day which sounds like
a fun cool date I want to know more
about this this would require one of two
situations occurring either one telling
them the truth and coming out when I'm
not ready or to lie to my parents there
are really great options any dubious
advice would be appreciated gay and
scared Elizabeth oh my god I want gay
and scared on a mug just classic at me
yeah well one kudos to you for being a
kid who doesn't want to lie to their
parents that's weird what's that like
and I mean I I always say like for
coming out when you live with your
parents it really comes down to like how
safe you feel so like if you feel like
they're going to react poorly and you're
going to have to find a different living
situation or there's some sort of like
abuse that's gonna happen or just
anything where you're not physically
safe I don't recommend coming out I used
to be really militant about like you
have to come out to show them that they
have a queer kid so they can change
their mind but now I'm sort of like the
practicality of it like if you don't
feel safe don't make yourself unsafe as
like a political statement but if also
like I don't know parents are dense so
like if you're like I'm gonna spend the
day with my female friend they'd be like
cool be gal pals have fun
I guess you Percy I guess you personally
don't feel good lying to them but like
what have you been doing up till now
right there's yeah I mean it's of course
it's like parent to parent situation
here but there there was a moment when
my parents were pretty sure I was gay
and and so this like like there were a
number of clues that were leading them
in that direction my interests my friend
group and you know because we have
stereotypes and I was fitting into some
of them so there I think you can like I
don't encourage this but there is
there's a sense that like you could be
like boy I sure but she seems like a
Lizabeth been hanging out with with with
Christina a whole lot lately seems like
there's been an all that in like not
just daytime but nighttime and a lot of
maybe they'll just sort of get it yeah
that's not necessarily how you want it
how you want to do I mean it's also like
and they might not they really might not
get it and also I don't mean to like I
don't know how old this person is and I
don't mean to like but like how long
look you could kind of get away with
sleepovers for like a while you know
what I mean before they know what's up
like you could sort of you can get like
door closed sleepovers for like a good
solid month before they're like what's
going on and like maybe you want to just
like do that for a bit cuz that look
there's so many disadvantages about
being queer that like let us have those
door closed sleepovers before you guys
realize what's up like give us that one
thing no one's getting pregnant it's
fine I die I also like I feel like I
like Elizabeth again good on you for
wanting to tell your parents the truth
and I think that being conflicted about
this at all is is the right place to be
and you have to make the decision based
on who you are and your situation did
your parents ever ask you like Hank
what's going on what why are you acting
no they they said they said things to
the to the tune of whoever you are
whoever you are it's okay with us
everybody should let me know yeah all
parents should do that totally agreed
regardless of if you think your kid is
gay cuz a lot of times like it that you
know there's very feminine girls who end
up being bisexual or queer ins or
lesbian and like their parents we're
like oh I guess we don't have to worry
but you you could start that just start
selling your kid that from day one
mm-hmm what were some of your interests
oh I really liked uh like going to the
skating rink and and just ice skating
not like like eventually I started
playing hockey but just like the free
skate I'll bike by myself I would go and
like like they like they play like pop
music and you just stayed around oh my
god all of my friends were female and
that that sort of remains a thing like I
of course I have dude friends but like
mostly it's like the husbands of my
friends are my dude friends did you ever
did you ever see that SNL skit that was
like like a wishing well for boys and it
was like and it was like a gift that you
get for like a young young boy and it's
like at that and it's just this like
sensitive boy who wants to like sit by a
well and then it's like the end of the
sketch is like it's not a gay thing I
mean it is but it's not and I was like
oh my god that's what you remind me of
the little sensitive boy next to the
well yeah and I really liked musicals
stuff like that oh you're just a
sensitive soul I mean what what it what
is what is what is it all as we have
found over the last 10 years it turns
out there are no boxes it sardor to put
people in boxes and that's the beautiful
thing we're all our own box
dear Gabby as I've become more senior at
work I find myself
erasing me for the podcast yep I've
become bored as I become more senior at
work I find myself in the position of
being asked to supervise or give
feedback to less experienced coworkers I
find this challenging firstly because
they do not want to hurt my co-workers
feelings secondly often is just easier
to fix their work myself but you know
this is not the best way to help my
co-workers grow professionally how do
you go about giving feedback in a way
that is one kind and to helps the person
fix their work and three gifts helps the
person
professionally for the next project ad
meloria meliora Jessica what's ad Mille
or we have a thing on our podcast for
people we compliment people on their on
their sign offs which has has resulted
in people making their sign offs really
weird I think it means it means the
better oh I don't know why are all the
best or something well you know a little
bit of a deep cut Jessica so don't make
us work for it
okay that was really good feedback back
to your coworker Jessica no I mean okay
well I think what's interesting and I
learned this from Allison primarily is
that you have to start it's like the
compliment sandwich so you have to start
with being like great job you did so
good on the lighting here's why the
sound is bad and I and I used to never
do that and I realize I was like why are
these babies that need me to just like
talk to them that way but turns out
everyone it's the babies are everyone
including me I'm also the baby yeah I
guess so why what's your advice no I
mean you you are the baby like you don't
like it when people would just like come
out and they're like here's the
criticism with none of the praise just
fix the thing that's wrong I assume
because you're a person but maybe maybe
you're the exception yeah sometimes I
like to just get to it but I can't but I
understand I understand that why I mean
you know there's this whole thing
especially as women and I'm sure Jess I
was about to lead with that with Jessica
like it's this hard thing as women in
supervising positions where you have to
sort of be like hey buddy like with this
smile on your face you can't just go up
and say what they need to do because
then everyone will be like Jessica's a
[ __ ] sorry now you're gonna bleep me
again but yeah so so I mean it's tough I
also understand the impulse to take over
but part of me is like like yes the work
will be done correctly the way you view
it as correctly but you've also hired
this person who may
have a different way of doing it and if
you ask them to fix it the way that they
do it will be different than the way
that you do it and that's okay and like
you wanted their skill set anyway so I
don't know I think you have to let go of
the idea that your way of doing it is
fixing it you know what I mean
let my making sense like your way of
doing it is not necessarily a hundred
percent correct you have to like be okay
with what the other person contributes
yeah and and I have struggled with that
where like I'll be like if it's not the
way I would have done it then it's wrong
it took me a while to get away from that
the other thing that I'll say to Jessica
that was really important for me to
realize is that when you say like it's
easier to fix their work myself you are
not giving yourself the chance to learn
and grow and become better at your job
which is the work that you have to do to
help your co-workers get better at their
jobs so you're not good at this part of
your job yet because it's new to you and
if you're just fixing their work if like
something is wrong and you're like oh
it's better it's easier for me to just
fix it than to have a conversation about
what's wrong then you're not getting
better at that you are doing the thing
that you like you're doing it to
yourself at the same time you're doing
it to your coworker so wouldn't you like
when you actually do it it's harder I
get you were like it's more difficult
work at first to figure out how to talk
to your coworker about how to make their
work better than it is to just make
their work better yourself but it's not
like that gets easier for you as well
just by doing it and by doing it over
and over again and like I now will
regularly send emails like I have to
figure out what I don't like about a
thing and I have to communicate that
effectively which is not necessarily
super easy but but I've gotten a lot
better at it and and at getting that
information across in a way and like
also understanding individual humans so
that I know the way to tell one person
is different than the way to tell
another person which is absolutely fine
like that's one of the things about
managing is understanding the people
that you manage not just like every
every person is the same and you should
treat them all the same I don't really
believe that I think that like you need
to understand what motivates different
people and and how they
how they respond to both praise and
criticism and what kind of praise and
what kind of criticism motivates them
the most which is rude shocking how
different people are especially how they
are not me over and over again I
continue to realize that other people
are not me yeah big a big important
lesson of management yeah big time and
you have to like it's gonna hurt their
feelings and and make them worse at
their job if you just do the work for
them so I think you gotta yeah I think
you you you can't you can't have you
can't have people working for you that
you're just doing their job for them cuz
then they'll just get resentful - it's a
bad pattern that's a good question damn
that's right we got we get lots of good
questions here either your Hank and John
I might ask another one if that sounds
like a good plan to you yeah go for it
this one I like a lot
it's from Christina who asks dear Hank
and Gaby I've been a nerdfighter and
involved in various fandoms for probably
seven plus years now in my younger teen
years I was really active in these
communities and I ate up as much content
IRL as I could
I'm 19 now and I feel this weird sense
of disassociation from it all I still
identify as a nerdfighter and love all
the content coming from all those other
fandoms that I was into but when I see
video of young teenage girls in the mass
of thousands screaming for these
youtubers that I adore I can't help but
feel uncomfortable I used to be that
girl I still unapologetically love all
these things but I feel weird about
conventions and IRL meetups do these
people they idol these people they
idolize are just people they binge watch
stranger things and wake up surrounded
and popcorn crumbs and regret just like
the rest of us am I just growing up am I
in am I in the wrong here we'll all
those adolescent girls I see at VidCon
crowds go through the same thing I am
Demming organs and self-doubt Christina
yes you're growing up as blink-182 said
that's what this is growing up so many
different times in that one song yeah I
guess this is growing up yeah I mean I
used to be super super into fandom like
I used to be
all it was like all-consuming but that
was because I was young and you I felt
powerless and I had you know I didn't
have the ability to like have a car and
live on my own and and do anything for
myself and I like wanted some kind of
feeling like I was a part of something
and I it was like yeah it's I've gone
through the almost the exact same thing
that Christine is describing where you
just kind of start to pull back and
you're like wait a minute everyone is a
person all your faves are problematic
like like nobody and I don't know if
this is just because I slowly became
like I was the person waiting in line
for these things and now at VidCon
people wait in line to see me and that
messes with me a lot like it's very
weird and so it gave me like this the
knowledge to know how to treat these
people and so like if you feel a little
disillusioned with it at least like take
it into your life of like okay I know
how to treat treat other people with
kindness because of how I would have
wanted to have been treated by these
people that were had like quote unquote
power over me I guess because I I
delight them but yeah it's just I think
it really is just growing up because you
start to realize that there's like other
stuff going on for you when you're young
there's not really I mean it's pretty
boring being well it's also like I think
that there's a lot of and this goes on
forever of course but there's a lot of
figuring yourself out and you're looking
for like models through which to figure
self out and that's both like the things
that you love and and like identifying
with those things and defining yourself
through the things that you love which
is a lot better than defining yourself
through the things that you hate yeah
and there's looking for people to sort
of be models for behavior and that's
both other people in communities or it's
the people that who are who are creating
the stuff that you love and I I mean I
was huge like nerd fan and I would wait
in long lines to meet my favorite
musicians and and authors and and and
also like totally like there will be
some people will go over a line mm-hmm
but I did that too like I was the guy
who went over the line me too like not
like everytime but like it like I there
are a couple of times maybe just one
time when I maybe figured out what hotel
a musician was staying at and I called
him on the phone and he answered and he
was like hello and I was like great show
tonight and he was like oh god that was
me and so now from now on whenever
somebody does something like that to me
I have to be like I like I can't really
complain that much yeah and I had like I
also think so it makes me and like
everything feels so important when
you're young like so important and so it
makes me have a lot of empathy for you
know for instance like when stuff
happens in queer fandom like when
lesbian characters are killed off or
when you know an actor that we really
loved says something homophobic or
transphobic or whatever and and it's
just like I understand how devastating
that is whereas like I think I'd see a
lot of people writing off teenage fandom
or like teen girls in particular where
they're like this is so silly this is so
dumb or they don't you know care about
them like the number one thing to me is
you don't alienate queer fandom and you
don't alienate teenage fandom like they
love so passionately and they care so
much because this is the most important
time in their life to them and so if
you're part of that like you should feel
so grateful and so lucky and so blessed
that they've even like connected with
you in some way so it is hard to draw
the line between like oh wow they're
really screaming and that's pretty
annoying
versus like putting into prayer you know
like people wanting to find my dad on
Facebook or whatever like I great I
completely get it like I get it so I
know I but growing up is starting to see
that that is crossing some sort of you
know that is crossing some sort of
boundary and that's why you shouldn't
behave that way into your 30s unless
you're like planning to murder someone I
guess well or or like I do
but like I'm super into like pictures of
moms at New Kids on the Block concerts
like you kits on the black one on a
reunion tour and like the pictures of 45
year old women at New Kids on the Block
concerts are my jam and like I love that
there still are those opportunities to
be like I'm gonna get in touch with that
I'm gonna remember what that was like
but you enjoy anything I want to show
you enjoy it and you don't stalk Jordan
yeah the other thing I want to say to
Christina is like as I've gotten older
the way that I like I think that the the
like the amount of appreciation and
enthusiasm I think I have for things
hasn't decreased I think maybe it's a
little more spread out and it's also
it's less focused on individual people
and more focused on like the sort of
broad scope like I'm less into like
Gordon gano from the Violent Femmes as I
am into like individual songs or
understanding like the complexities of a
rhyme scheme or or even like a marketing
strategy that may be a musician youth
that is that is really like like
positive and like smart effective and
like good for the world like if you
could like finding those ways that like
I appreciate people in very different
ways now and I often it's not so much
about like sort of all focused on this
my imagined version of what their
personality is because of course it's
always imagined when it's not it's even
when it is a person you know even when
it's yourself there's a lot of imagining
that goes on but I find that like I'm
still super like when I find something
that I love like a you know when I get
into a new podcast or a new book series
or something like I still love it and
like really deep in passionate ways but
it's focused in a different way and I
don't think that that means that it and
like and at VidCon we try to have like
all of those kinds of discussions going
on where it's like yes there's places
for screaming and going crazy and
there's places for like but let's have
conversations about like the effect that
these things are having or that
difficulties people are facing or the
exciting things that are happening
yeah it's also realizing that people
aren't perfect is they're really big
like I am still obviously like you
should obviously still have passions and
love stuff but like realizing that it's
my stuff's become less person focused
too because it you you get disappointed
by people and that's why I don't date
fans because I feel like what am I gonna
do just disappoint them because
everyone's like like oh but you seem
like you would like take advantage of
that kind of thing no that's horrible
that's like that's like first of all
thanks thanks for saying that about me I
was like I'm like I'm I don't know what
the word with proper word to use on this
podcast is lothario but like I'm not
like like there's a power dynamic and I
think they allowed it like yeah you just
start to slowly not focus on individual
people as much I think in Mike and my
experience I had the Google lothario so
I did that annoying a male given name
which is suggest an unscrupulous seducer
of women yeah that seems right that
checks out dear Gabby and I guess Hank I
want to get a fairly realistic I want to
get a fairly realistic tattoo of Saturn
but it feels like NASA updates their
images of Saturn every few weeks
should I get a tattoo based on the
current available images of Saturn and
just accept that it'll be a snapshot of
what Saturn looked like at the time I
got the tattoo knowing it will change
throughout my life or should I wait
indefinitely until space photography has
advanced
general woody general witty sign-off
Janina this is incredible eyes awaited
definitely until space photography
advances before getting my Saturn tattoo
I actually have an answer for this
question that's pretty straightforward
so NASA is currently updating their
images of Saturn a whole lot because
there is a there's a mission that is at
Saturn and taking lots of great pictures
of Saturn it's called Cassini and it
rocks and Saturn is a lot of people's
favorite planet unless I assume aside
from Earth and it's a beautiful planet
but it the images so basically that was
like a 20 year maybe 30 year period when
we
didn't get any new pictures of Saturn
and then we started to get these new
ones and they're great and then we're
not going to get any new ones for a long
time so you might want to wait six
months until the current crop of Cassini
photos get a really like a bunch of good
post production done on them cuz I don't
think that there are any new ones coming
in anymore but it does sometimes take a
little while for the artists who like
take the raw data and make it into
something that's like oh damn that's a
beautiful planet to happen so you might
want to wait about six months and then
you will have I think pretty much all
we're gonna get out of Cassini and then
we won't have any new photographs of
Saturn for like decades
unfortunately so we're just we just
happen to be living in an amazing time
for Saturn photographs
Janina do you have any tattoos I don't
have any single tattoos I'm tattoo less
interesting because I feel like and this
is my non science answer I have a bunch
of tattoos and I feel like when people
go oh but won't you regret it I feel
like that is a snapshot in time of what
I was at that time so it might be cool
to get a picture of Saturn now knowing
that when you look back that you'll know
that it was specifically from this time
in your life does that make sense yeah
which is why I should get a tattoo of
like the current shape of Antarctica
because that's going to change a lot too
before I die yeah like this is what it
looked like when I was a kid y'all back
when there was more of it that will be
so depressing Hank so do you have
tattoos Gaby I know you have tattoos but
tell me about it tell me about your
tattoo sitch
oh I have seven of them I'm about to get
more I think but I yeah I know a lot of
them I just did kind of on a whim and
then that's how I think about it is like
you at 22 thought this was cool and so
that's not something like that's not
something to be ashamed of at 29 like
that's you know it's kind of like a like
a photo album or something about like
what you I mean I have a tattoo on my
hand and I was like oh I really
committed to show business I guess like
yeah a lot of it is just kind of what I
what I thought was in
at the time and so when I saw that
question I was like oh be cool to just
have Saturn now as it as it is to you at
whatever age you are and then as it
changes you can see how it changed
throughout talk like you know throughout
your life that would be kind of cool
yeah I mean to be clear Saturn house
itself has not changed that much just to
Star ability to take good pictures of it
has changed people come away with the
wrong image that Saturn is out there
doing like some kind of weird dancing
some days it's a square mostly the same
what would you get a tattoo of if you
got one oh I don't know I what I have I
have felt like more like getting a
tattoo since I turned like 37 a sign
that I'm headed it I'm headed into a
midlife crisis like I think it's I think
that that's what's happening yeah
whatever at this point exactly you know
I wrote a thing when I was in college
and said I want a job where when I when
I turned 40 I can get a mohawk and it
won't be won't be bad for my career
and I kind of feel like that's the case
but I also kind of feel like I can't
have a mohawk and teach a crash course
why people be like who is this 40 year
old man with a mohawk trying to teach me
about chemistry no what about that guy's
NASA that has the mohawk yeah I mean
yeah except that that guy is a
attractive young man yeah and I am a I
am an attractive old man I was like
about to yell at you so good that you
specified but what would you get I don't
I I feel like I had something oh I was
thinking about the the end of the Origin
of Species was real good
what is that I'm gonna read it to you
but I can't remember it it's a words I
was saying you should get words I like
when men have yeah I like when men have
words tattoos you like men you like men
man word tattoos I like when men yo and
men have like just black and like just
text that's very tracked my my my cousin
is a tattoo artist and he won't do words
he refuses to do words so I guess I
can't go to my cousin but it's it's this
from it's the like the last paragraph of
On the Origin of Species where he laid
out the theory of evolution it says
there is grandeur in this view of life
with its several powers having been
originally breathed into a few forms or
into one and that whilst this planet has
gone cycling on according to the fixed
law of gravity from so simple a
beginning endless forms and most
beautiful and most wonderful endless
forms endless forms most beautiful and
most wonderful have been and are being
evolved which is just like sometimes we
forget that Charles Darwin was a great
writer Wow is and now you maybe curse
again on this podcast you got two of
them out of me oh I've done my job I'm
saying so on Brent
you should get like the part that just
says like endless forms of wonderful and
beautiful or something like that yeah
sure sure that's a lot of words I want
to get just pain don't hurt from
Roadhouse so I'm also an intellectual
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's good
di think it thought about getting the
dftba tattoo I feel like that's on brand
but just just a reminder and and part of
me at one point in my in my life where I
wanted to get every like every logo of
every business I started tattooed on me
and then and then somebody was like
that's the worst thing I've ever heard
so don't do that where would you get it
I I mean the only place I'm interested
in getting tattoos is my forearms
because I like forearm tattoos are my
jam
I like forearms I think that they're one
of the best parts of the body yeah and
also they're really there's this a good
tattoo place because for I'm skin for
some reason scent tends to stay nice and
good skin for some reason yeah that's
like that's like the I was gonna say so
that's what I like I like dudes with
like word tattoos black ink word tattoos
on their arms that's very classy and
sexy you should do that pain don't hurt
I could get pain don't hurt pain don't
hurt I'm such trash okay and that leads
us of course to our sponsors for this
episode our sponsor our first sponsor is
word tattoos on the mail for on word
tattoos in black ink on the male forearm
the best kind of tattoos if you want to
be admired by Gabby done which everyone
does it's also you brought to you by the
movie Roadhouse it's a really good movie
it didn't just come out it's from the
80s but it's on no it's on Hulu so check
it out
what can you tell me if that movie Point
Break was a spinoff of Roadhouse or were
they just sort of like Venn diagrams
that that sort of puzzled into each
other a little bit
Oh Point Break do I know Point Break the
greatest queer love story of our time
yeah I do
yeah it's an incredible movie about how
Keanu Reeves falls in love with Patrick
Swayze
I don't know like yeah it's it's funny
because there's there there is a there
is a female love interest in that movie
I understand that she's peripheral and
basically discarded as schoolies as soon
as she fulfills her her mission of being
a damsel yeah but she's there hold on
she has short hair and her name is Tyler
Kathryn Bigelow Kathryn Bigelow being
the director of Point Break
anyway our podcast is additionally
brought to you by those good good
closed-door sleepovers get you can
squeeze like a month of them in maybe
before people will start disrespect and
brought to you by the planet Saturn it's
a square now finally this podcast is
brought to you by our actual our actual
sponsor which is also a square it is a
square space as squares it's just square
space Ali aah you've heard of squirt
what I owe you
I gave you that whoa yeah that was a
good I love you is a good Ally do you
know that you know about Squarespace I
do that
that's how we have Gabby and Alison calm
is on Squarespace oh look at you yeah
and also if you want to if you want to
find out how to get a signed copy of my
brother's new book turtles all the way
down you can go to probably sign turtles
calm which is also a Squarespace site
Hey
Squarespace is a place where you can
really easily make very pretty websites
and then you have a website to do with
what you want whether that's they have
like an e-commerce platform but there's
also just like sort of brochure II
things where you can have a presence
that says here's what I am and what I do
which can help you get work get jobs it
is good to have it is good to have a
website I always had one until well I
guess I still do have one but it's not
on Squarespace I really need to fix that
because it's really not great well
that's the thing well because like I
regret that it's done on Squarespace
because it like it's hard for me to
update it because it's based on all this
old technology that I probably am open
to hacking because it doesn't
automatically update itself the way that
Squarespace does so I really do need to
get on that and create a new Squarespace
for my site where it will always be
updated and I don't have to worry about
the server and I don't have to worry
about any like all kind of like all the
different pieces that fit together or
being hacked or anything like that
Squarespace is going to take care of all
of it with 24/7 customer support and
really nice looking templates that look
good both on mobile and desktop which my
website doesn't keep your eye open for a
new a new hankering com that's made by
Squarespace I'm really looking forward
to that you got this there are not many
Hank greens in the world Gaby what seems
like a very common name alright also I
will say that like I was pretty active
on the internet in like 1998 so um at
which maybe is when I registered Hank
Green Comm nice uh yeah Squarespace make
your next move and you can do that and
you get a coupon if you go to
squarespace.com slash dear Hank and or
use the offer code dear Hank you could
also use Dear John but you don't need to
because he's not here today
don't use dear Gaby though that won't
work
rude I I was soaked we were like
freaking out when your brother said that
his book was coming out in the fall and
Alison and I were like if it is on the
same day as ours we will come oh where
in your offices okay
what day what day does your book come
out September 5th okay yeah your beer
way ahead yeah you got full month before
before John starts sucking up the oxygen
yeah yeah we're okay but it was cute I
saw an Amazon it said like these two
often bought together and it was John's
book in our book and I was like oh wow
that's amazing
adorable so tell me about your book by
the way
oh yeah Alison and I wrote a young adult
novel together called I hate everyone
but you and it's about two girls that go
away to college and spoiler they're like
similar to me and Alison and and they go
away to college on separate coasts and
one of them is dealing with mental
illness and she wants to be normal and
have a boyfriend to join a sorority but
she also like can't touch the sheets and
then so is like having a lot of problems
and then with depression and anxiety and
then the other girl that goes to school
in Boston and she's coming out and
dealing with like ethical quandary Xand
and so yeah it's like basically if we
had known each other during our actual
college days and then that's can they
stay friends even though they are so
different it's like a fringe it's a
friendship love story it's like a
friendship rom-com yeah yeah yeah you
got and you got that good Odd Couple
thing going and it's told through their
communications right so there's like a
name for that kind of book that I forget
what it is an epistolary novel there it
is yeah it's told through text messages
and emails and yeah so that was once
person told us that they loved that
because it wasn't to exposit or II you
just really like jump in and get to get
to know them which is nice and
personally I've been really happy
because we've gotten a lot of really
good like a lot of good lists and a lot
of good reviews specifically
how the queer stuff is handled and that
was like a really big deal to me so I
was super happy with like people
singling out I mean saying the book is
good in general but singling out like
the queer and trans stuff which was I
was like really I put a lot of myself
into so I was happy that people cared so
that comes out okay so that comes out of
September September 5th and then we
start going on tour right after that and
nice yeah so you can see stuff about the
book and the tour at Gabby and Alison
calm and the tours like starts the day
the book comes out September 5th in
Philly
are you coming to Missoula no and it's
not it's not just a book tour it's also
like a live [ __ ] we're doing like a live
show right so it's like you know John
and I are doing the same thing yeah bang
for your buck which I can't I can't talk
about it all yet I apologize for having
talked to that much about it but there
will be a tour obviously the same time
as ours because again I will come to
your house I don't know how late those
years ago ours starts October 10th okay
yeah yeah we won't overlap good good
good okay yeah I want to come to
Missoula as you were things we talked
about I want to like check out what the
what the like the gay the LGBT scene is
there in your hip little Montana town
mm-hmm I bet I can I can I can get you
clued in yeah I bet it's poppin off well
yeah like I think it's pretty it's
pretty late I was hanging out with a a
with a friend of mine who is in that
scene yesterday and she said oh like I
just sort of don't go outside the
triangle and I was like what's the
triangle and she like laid out for me
the map where like they're like the
where the roads are and she was like if
you stay in inside of all these roads
it's like queer utopia and if you go on
the other side then it's like you've
stuck in looks and I'm like well welcome
to Montana I'm glad we have a triangle
for it you Gabby do you want to do like
one or two more questions yeah this one
comes from Andrew who asks dear Hank and
Gabby everybody knows that mugs have
handles what do you call a mug without a
handle is it a cup surely it can't be a
glass as that would mean it would be
made out of glass be safe out there
Andrew be safe out there is one of my
face
it's from the episode that is a real
good sign off and I'm gonna use it more
be safe out there implies what what's
happening out there I just did just in
general I think safety is important yeah
I make everyone text me when they get
back to their house from my house do you
do that no no I don't I live inside the
triangle that's good like just like
because what what if they go missing and
then I end up having to be like like in
their trial giving testimony right and
then I'm the last person that saw them I
had wait can I tell you something messed
up I had okay as long as you're not
admitting to murder no no I had an
ex-boyfriend who was like very like very
funny but like very dark sense of humor
and he and I was joking and I was like
if I ever die and I go missing without a
trace like he did it but if I die and
it's just blood everywhere and it was a
crime of passion then Alison did it and
then they were laughing and then he goes
what makes you think I wouldn't spread
your blood around and frame Alison it's
too much true crap oh yeah but yeah so
but but back to the back to the mug yeah
I don't know how he got to murder but
yeah that that's very dear Hank and John
of us I think I'm loved without a handle
is just a piece of crap like it's just
useless BS that shouldn't exist because
the whole point is this for hot stuff
and if you don't have a handle not
adequately protecting yourself from the
hot stuff have you ever been to a
restaurant where they give you like hot
tea or coffee in a glass cup no because
that is illegal and or it should be no
they do that here in LA all the time and
I don't under do you want me to be hurt
like I don't understand it makes me feel
oh yes it makes me so mad
it's a hot beverage why are you putting
it in a
and they put it in a glass cup I've seen
it Hank it's real it's just basically
like putting your hand straight into the
coffee that's what they're asking you to
do yeah happened to me why no it's
terrible that's awful
you know I when I saw this question I
was like you know I kind of feel like
I've seen like a ceramic mug that I
would call a mug that doesn't have a
handle yeah cuz it's got like those
thick mug walls and it's mug shaped but
it doesn't and so I googled it and
they're called months without handles
that's it that's what they're called
there's no special name there you can
like go if you like search for mugs that
handles it's just like mugs without
handles available at these places for
minimalist design nuts these mugs don't
have handles on oh here I'm here on it
yeah minimalist I don't want a handle on
my mug I want to be in pain they're also
very small I mean you just have like a
little like my tiny mind I'm like look I
don't like I can't even have a coffee
it's just espresso we don't have space
for coffee if you go to someone's house
and they hand you a mug without a handle
call the police they are a murderer just
throw it on the ground like Thor in the
Thor movie and then walk out and say I
won't have another and then or just go
to all their mugs and break them all and
say they're more mugs better than this
are available at dftba.com I mean this
is just with handles useless useless I
mean I don't know if we solved this
person they're called useless next
question okay we're gonna finish off
with a question from anonymous dear Hank
and Gabby so I made quite a mess of my
sexuality when I was hitting puberty
around 13 years of age or so I was very
certain that I was lesbian I dated a
girl in secret when I was 15 both
parties parents found out our lives
turned into an HBO special you know the
drill my parents weren't cool with it
and one thing my mom said was if you're
bi please just try to be straight she
said this with the best intentions but
it's
me in a fun situation because I spent
years trying to convince myself I'm
straight I've dated several boys and it
wasn't until I had a sexual encounter
with one of these boys that I felt 100%
almost magnetic repulsion sort of
feeling of no this is incorrect and icky
and please don't do this that I realized
that I'm SuperDuper gay so now I'm
almost 23 and I'm in the situation of
finding on the outside men and women
completely equally attractive but being
100% not interested in anything
involving men how do I come out to my
parents and explain to them without
seeming like I have a choice to date men
still I know asking two straight guys
might be the best choice but I'm
desperate and looking for any dubious
advice anywhere I can find it ok I have
great news for you oh yeah you've come
to the right place hello I don't know if
the people listening know that I'm but
I'll just say I'm a syst bisexual woman
that if so that people know my
credentials where did you degree from in
by studies it's it's from the Kristen
Stewart school I have a master's degree
in threesomes ok so I have a master's
degree in dating couples ok so this
basically you you live in a patriarchal
society and a heteronormative society
that teaches you that the right thing to
do is to be straight and no one is
immune to it and no one is no one is
like strong enough usually to shrug all
that off which is why there's so money
there's so much higher rates of suicide
and depression in particularly bisexual
but also all kinds of queer people and
and so your your mom I don't know if
best intentions was the right way to put
that because I think although I think
you're trying to say that she was sort
of like I just want you to have an
easier life and I don't want you to cuz
I actually I just was hanging out with
two friends of mine one is a lesbian one
is an immigrant and I was like who do
you think has it worse between the three
of us joking and without missing a beat
they were both like you do so
being bi is tough and I think that you
could maybe just dumb it down for your
parents like I think you can just say
like look I'm gay because if you don't
want to date men maybe it's not worth
trying to explain to them that like
sexuality is fluid and that like a lot
of times if you're if you're because
like bisexuality has a lot to do with
desire versus action in my mind so if
you there are some people who do have do
bi sexual acts sexually but they're not
they don't identify as bisexual because
they're designed they don't desire to to
be romantic with men and women and so
there's like this split between like you
know you can be like hetero-romantic
bisexual or like homo-romantic bisexual
or and it sounds like you think you can
see that they're both attractive but
you're only romantically interested in
women and sounds like sexually
interested in women so I think it might
be because they're from a different
generation and because it seems like
they don't really get it
or you might be interested in just
distilling it down for them and being
like look look I'm a lesbian and maybe
that's not like the whole truth to you
but it's also the easiest way to get
them off your back since like my parents
are sort of weirdos and are like open to
a lot of stuff so I feel like I could
set them down and explain this type of
thing but most baby boomers I'm assuming
are your parents are not like I don't
know they just you just have to know who
your parents are and if they're the type
that need things to be black and white
then for your own sanity maybe just
present it that way mm-hmm I mean I also
think the whole thing of like well if
you're bi just please try to be straight
it's like it's not a choice it's not a
choice to who for who you are attracted
to or who you fall in love with so it's
like to be like if you're super into
this woman but they're like can you just
choose to be straight like you're not
going to
be like oh yeah let me just put that on
the back burner and give the old
straight straight tinder ago which by
the way is a nightmare place never go on
straight straight tinder it's horrendous
but yeah I mean I don't know it's
interesting because I there was this
interview it's Cynthia Nixon where she
was talking about how people assume
she's a lesbian and she was like no I'm
I'm sorry she's like I'm more bisexual
but I've just decided that dating women
is better and everyone lost their minds
and was like yeah you're saying that
being a like you're saying that being a
lesbian is a choice but a lot but like I
was sort of like yeah but if you if you
are like I am attracted to both but I
just am only romantically interested in
this one particular situation then
that's you can define that however you
wanted to find that I don't think that's
I don't know like I've met men who are
like yeah I'm straight I mean I've like
done stuff with dudes but I only want to
date women and I'm like then you're then
say that you're straight and other men
that have said that same thing have said
that they identify as bi it's really
very like whatever feels right rolling
off your tongue about yourself but I
also think to your to your parents you
gotta just get them off your back and
distill it I think yeah give them give
them a thing that that is easy enough to
process yeah yeah and I mean I like I
don't know if you're worried that
they're gonna be like but you dated all
those dudes so cuz then you can just be
like I did it cuz because no homosexual
person has ever had a heterosexual
relationship ever right like you just be
like I try like even now that's your mo
you can go I gave it a shot
not for me really true I did a bunch
yeah I really tried oh my god that was
so funny I really tried so many dudes
not me
mom I gotta tell you I mean I I tried I
tried it with every guy I could try oh I
tried out of them work tried it all the
ways and they're so upset like was that
not what you
oh all right well it is nap time for the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon the
news from Mars
I'll go first is that there is now a
game that was designed in partnership
with NASA and if you have a HTC vive or
any of the other modern VR devices you
can go to Mars yourself at home in your
a little vibe space if you have one of
those I don't but I so I have not been
able to try this but the basic idea is
that you land yourself on Mars and this
isn't just like a landscape that looks
like Mars it taken from data from the
MSO orbiter and it's basically an area
of Mars that actually exists you land on
it you can go over your little habit
pavatt ation module you can drive your
little rover around you could do soil
and rock collections and then once you
do that you open up new areas of the map
and you get to see other cooled areas of
of the planet and basically you just get
to hang on the surface of Mars which no
actual human it's going to get to do for
quite a long time hopefully before 2028
but for quite a long time and yeah and I
would like to do it but I don't have any
VR gear so if anybody gets the chance to
play Mars 2030 please tell me how it
goes are you would you go like I guess
not you have a baby but if they were
like you go go live on Mars now you
would be like I mean I have a friend I
have a friend who is has several
children and he is super like Tron he's
actively trying to become an astronaut
and I'm like Jesus I don't know that I
would do that he wants to live on Mars
no no he wants to be an astronaut which
to me is just like it's dangerous is a
very dangerous job Wow but but no I
don't think he wants to go live on Mars
I would not go live on Mars there's a
bunch of reasons why I wouldn't go live
on Mars I used to want to go live on
Mars but that that changed as I got
older and more emotion sick yeah and you
saw the Martian and you're like oh
growing potatoes for so long just like
action movie so what's the news from AFC
Wimbledon Gabby
oh well as you know our lead starter
mark Harrington he's been really sick
and so he's he's had the flu so he's
been out of several games and that means
that our ticket our second starter this
guy his name is Karl ranks he's been
he's been playing and you know he hasn't
really had a chance to shine but now he
scored three goals in the last ball game
so he now everyone's like yeah so now
everyone's like well maybe we don't even
need Barr Carrington maybe we just means
Karl ranks and mark Harrington's
pissed I heard that gossip in the locker
room that he's real mad so he might be
treated to a totally different team and
and his best friend is on AFC Wimbledon
and his best friend is Lisa Simpson not
related to the Simpson and so she is
she's like well if he goes then I'm
gonna go but that's really awful because
she's our best goalkeeper so my thoughts
are maybe that once mark Harrington is
better they should just let him the
coach whose name is Kate Moss she should
let she should let maybe have them both
play like a double a double starter
which I know hasn't been done since the
1940s I know no team has had a double
starter since the 1940s okay I get it
but I think in my my opinions
controversial I think we should do it
and that's all the news from mister to
Wimbledon a real team that exists good
John we'll be back next week with real
news from AFC Wimbledon Hill careful
catch everybody up
hey let me know if they do that double
starter okay what I'll be really
interested I'll ask John directly if
they do the double starter or not and he
will he will be really interested to
tell me the answer
Gaby what do we learn today what did we
learn we learned that you should get a
forearm tattoo of just text because I
would be super sexy
we also learned all right that all of
your faves are problematic and have
written erotica we also learned that
[Music]
forgot about the shell silver that
you're a creep who calls people at their
hotel rooms like 12 who did you call the
lead singer of demo page ayats what did
we learned the meaning of the word
lothario we learned I did you already
knew and I also learned the meaning of
the word epistolary which is in
reference to Gaby's new book yes thank
you for helping me to really just promo
the new book please oh please okay hit
it harder preorder it free order it
please and what's it called
did you tell did you tell us what it was
called it's called I hate everyone but
you okay
you did you did say that but I always
wanted you to say it again you're so
good at this please help me okay and and
we learned don't do the work for your
co-workers that's right good yes we
learned all of those things wait there
we deliver more what else do we learn
lie to your parents so you can have gay
sex all right in addition to promoting
everything I hate about you we also I
there's a game that I'm developing that
I have developed with some friends
available on Kickstarter it's called
Ralph it's really fun you can watch on
Hanks channel me playing it which is my
youtube channel
that no one knows about youtube.com
slash Hank's channel it's just me and
you could find out more about that and I
would love it if you check it out maybe
see if you want to back it on
Kickstarter and also I will be in
Australia for VidCon Australia September
9th
if you are interested in coming to see
me John won't be there so just like this
podcast except without Gabby either you
aren't coming are you no but I'm going
to pod con your other thing oh oh yeah
also pod con it's still still thing and
pod contacts are available again if you
were didn't get them during the
indiegogo but when I get them out and
we'll be talking more about pod con as
it approaches it's coming up in December
in Seattle so I'm excited to see you at
pod con Gabi thank you for hanging out
and yeah you're good thank you for being
a guest thank you for being a guest on
my new sexy podcast your Gabi
all we do is Kirsten talk about your
idols who wrote erotica this podcast
dear Gabi is an antenna class Jenkins
our producers are rosianna halse rojas
and shared and gibson our social media
manager is the Corey Bongiorno the music
is by the great gunnarolla if you would
like to email us you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com and as they
say in our hometown
[Music]